okay today i'm going to talk to you
about cracking
the whole purpose of cracking is to turn
longer
less useful hydrocarbon chains into
smaller
more useful hydrocarbon chains so
cracking
is an example of a thermal decomposition
reaction now all that thermal
decomposition means
is breaking down using heat so during
cracking
we use heat to break down these longer
chains
the temperature is normally ranges
between 400 degrees c
and 700 degrees c and it's normally
carried out at around
70 atmospheres in pressure
so let's see what this actually means
so for cracking we start off with
a long chain
hydrocarbon so just to remind you a
hydrocarbon
is a molecule which is made of just
carbon
and hydrogen now they start off all with
single bonds so these
are saturated the way that i remember
saturated is s is for single bonds s is
for saturated
now this molecule might not be as useful
as a shorter chained
unsaturated one so what we can do
is undergo cracking which is a thermal
decomposition reaction
so we add heat to break these strong
covalent bonds and these are the
products
that we get first of all
we get a shorter alkane
so i'll just draw that right now
remember
no atoms are being created or destroyed
so once
i've finished showing the products we
should have the same number of carbons
and hydrogens
in our reactants compared to our product
okay
so one of the products we get after
cracking is a shorter
alkane than before
and another thing that we're going to
get as well in addition to this
is an alkene
now i know that this is an alkene
because it has a double bond a carbon to
carbon double bond right here
now these alkenes first of all they are
unsaturated
because they have a double bond
this means they could be used for
they could be used for to kind of
undergo reactions
for example they could be used in the
process of
polymerization in particular addition
polymerization
so these alkenes can be used
in order to create plastics so as you
can see we've taken a longer
less useful hydrocarbon chain using heat
and a catalyst that we'll look at in a
minute
we've broken that down into a shorter
alkane which could be more useful
and an alkene which could be used for
lots of different things for example in
the process of polymerization
so that's the basics of cracking now
in a lab we might have an experiment
that looks a bit like this all this is
is a tube a glass tube
and in both ends there's a bung now what
we actually have
in there is we have
a catalyst now all the catalyst does is
speeds up the rate of reaction
without being used up a suitable
catalyst
is aluminium oxide
so if i was doing this in a lab what i
could do
is first of all i would heat because
remember it needs to be thermal
decomposition
so we need an element of heat i'd heat
up this
longer hydrocarbon
and vaporize it now once it was
vaporized
it could be passed through
this tube
while as it goes over the catalyst it
catalyzes the reaction
and therefore it's going to be broken
down into
our two products so coming out of the
other side
in the lab this is where we'd have a
shorter
alkane alkane
and also we'd have coming out uh alkene
so this is just an equipment that we
could use in the laboratory
in order to do a cracking experiment so
breaking that down
now the final thing we need to know
about cracking
is this here how it operates in industry
so when we have the fractional
distillation of crude oil
there's another video where you can
learn more about that but when we
basically a fraction distillation crude
oil
we have lots of different fractions
produced
these are fractions in order of how long
the
chain length is so lpg here
has three carbons in the chain so it's
very very short
whereas fuel oil and bitumen have an
average number of carbon atoms of around
80. so as we can see there's different
lengths
of within each fraction
what we can also see is if i was to
uh do the fractional distillation of
crude oil only
two percent of that um distillation
would be comprised of lpg whereas a
massive
50 percent of that would be fuel oil and
bitumen
now this is when it gets interesting
because we could see why cracking could
be so important
if we look at how much there is in oil
crude oil compared to how much is in
demand
we can see that these shorter chained
hydrocarbons particularly
lpg and petrol
we need them more than the
more than the amount that we produce
whereas
if i look at uh fuel oil and bitumen 50
of the constitution of crude oil is made
up from these fractions
but i only require about 38
so this is why we could do cracking in
order to break down
these longer less useful hydrocarbons
into these smaller more useful
hydrocarbons
and that basically is how cracking works
thank you